é
é é
em
2013 para mim foi um ano muito Market
foi um
Marco histórico
porque a juventude foi para rua porque
eu e a Nina uma grande amiga abrimos a
escola de jornalismo para jovens de 15 a
21 anos e porque eu fiquei grávida da
Tereza as manifestações de junho de 2013
provocaram uma mudança no eixo da
comunicação e do jornalismo no Brasil
muito importantes Porque surgiu uma
galera chamada de mídia ninja que foi
para Rua ligou o celular e começou a
filmar o que estava acontecendo nos
olhos de quem via e isso obrigou a
tradicional mídia brasileira a descer
dos helicópteros e saídas redações para
tentar entender o que que tava
acontecendo
teve que inclusive voltar atrás se
retratar reconhecer violência policial
reconhecer potência de movimento
Oi
eu tava na rua com a turma da escola de
Jornalismo
e na rua a gente começou a entender que
o jornalista jornalismo é feito
desenvolvido por homens brancos e da
região central
simplesmente não representa a maioria
com vocês a maioria da população
brasileira
53 por cento da população brasileira são
pessoas negras 51 por cento e a mulher
Parabéns Protex que super contemplou As
mulheres hoje
e setenta por cento da moradores de
periferias E aí a gente começa né
partindo daí a gente começa a gente
verdade parece que saia tudo minoria né
mas não
então as mulheres são 51 por cento Mas
elas são nove porcento do Parlamento né
do do congresso nacional os negros são
53 por cento Mas eles só são 10 por
menos de 10 porcento dos Jornalistas nas
redações brasileiras ele falou para
precisamos mudar isso é demais
diversidade vamos dar uma ensinada para
essa grande em frente Aí essa é a Nina
e a Nina é a minha alma gêmea é gêmea
porque dizer minha gente não tem nada
mesmo ela é minha alma gêmea Porque é
ela que faz os projetos da é nóis da
escola de jornalismo ela que instiga os
meninos e as meninas que estão lá com a
gente a construírem o jornalismo que não
existe a construírem o Jornalismo do
Futuro A experimentar
e a gente se conheceu no mercado de
talião nas redações E aí em 2009 a gente
decidiu fazer uma oficina de jornalismo
voluntariamente numa ONG numa região
muito violência da cidade de São Paulo
na zona sul
e aí a gente foi para lá achando que
ensinar né aí Vamos ensinar jornalismo
pra galera e tal na favela na periferia
e o que aconteceu lá é que a gente
aprendeu muitas coisas
muito mais do que ensinou a gente levou
Nossa maletinha com as ferramentas do
jornalismo o que que é pauta o que que é
vídeo O que que a câmera o que que é
como contar uma boa história mas a gente
percebeu que tinham muitas histórias ali
para serem contadas e não é que a gente
foi lá dar vossa ninguém todo mundo tem
voz todo mundo pode comprar sua história
e a gente aprender entender o que era
isso aí que as pessoas podiam contar
suas histórias e a gente descobriu que o
jornalismo acreditem é uma p***
ferramenta e até mesmo essa frase que
ela é boa você descobrir conhecer o
mundo e transformar a realidade
aí o povo pergunta Legal vocês vivem da
escola de jornalismo tal essa história
toda mas e aí qual é o modelo de negócio
todos
vocês não fazem nenhum fila como é que
você vem o dinheiro a gente vive disso
muito bem Obrigada das mais diversas
formas possíveis tem dinheiro de edital
tem dinheiro de empresa tem dinheiro de
lei de incentivo e tem dinheiro de
pessoa física que é uma coisa que a
gente gosta muito tem muito orgulho
apesar de dar muito trabalho para
acontecer
essa é a plataforma da escola de
jornalismo é é a nossa nosso lado online
digital moderno e a gente construiu essa
história com códigos abertos Então quem
quiser copiar fica à vontade é a partir
do financiamento de pessoas físicas
foram 400 pessoas
doando dinheiro a gente chegou em r$
a&f super Suada essa história mas vale a
pena porque hoje a gente tem cinco mil
alunos aí e
isso representa muito a bandeira que a
gente carrega que é da democratização da
produção do conteúdo porque acesso a
gente tem tá todo mundo aqui conectado
no wi-fi do café tá todo mundo mandando
foto selfie 360
é mas a gente ainda não está empoderado
para contar nossas próprias histórias a
gente delega isso para Aquela nossa
redação super né de minorias ali então
foi uma coisa muito importante para a
gente e a maneira de financiar a partir
de pessoa física
foi tão difícil
porque as picantes ainda o saco dos
amigos no Facebook aí dá um dinheiro aí
compra na lojinha não sei que ainda é
uma postura que a gente não tá
acostumado e que a gente fica meio
constrangido né melhor a gente tal mas
todo mundo dia para fazer um caldo de
carne na vida para entender o que é eu
mesmo só a minha filha só nasceu depois
que a gente bateu a meta dos 40 mil
reais
e
a Teresa nasceu um ano depois que nós
nasceu e eu vou contar para vocês como
aí nós nasceu o primeiro tá vamos lá na
nossa linda oficina de jornalismo
voluntária já pensando mano como vamos
ganhar dinheiro precisamos ganhar
dinheiro que a gente se Nessa altura do
campeonato já tinha pedido demissão já
tinha mudado de namorado eu tava aquela
confusão porque foi muito transformador
ter ido ensinar jornalismo é é muito
potente e a juventude é muito potente E
aí todo lá tava ensinando jornalismo
aprendendo de jornalismo na de repente a
Vivo Vivo Alô Vivo telefonia tal chega
nesse lugar que se chama Parque Santo
Antônio para fazer Business subi três
antenas de celular melhorar o final para
que as pessoas usem mais o serviço não
para fazer negócio ele fala tudo tudo
bem além de melhorar a qualidade de
serviço estamos a melhorar É o afeto de
marca vamos atrair mais pessoas para o
nosso serviço E aí decidiram chamar onde
que a gente tá E aí e a pessoal da
comunidade para decidir o que fazer
então para se integrar melhor para a
comunidade E aí decidiram fazer esse
diagnóstico eles descobriram que melhora
fazer um campeonato de futebol no único
espaço de lazer de uma comunidade de 15
mil habitantes que no campinho de Várzea
a massa a gente viu a movimentação calor
o pessoal da comunicação flor Oi tudo
bem E aí quem vai fazer comunicação
nessa história quem vai fazer a
comunicação do campeonato aí eu lembro
que a menina da comunicação ele vai
ficar assim pessoal da Young nossas
agências de Publicidade Jeffrey Linda
adoro sei que você tem aí uma gente é
que esse padrão 300 milhões de reais por
ano para fazer seus comerciais vender
seus produtos e tudo mais eu quero saber
quem vai trazer torcida
o
pro gente tem aqui uma redação formada
por 30 meninos e meninas desta
comunidade que tem um projeto para te
apresentar e foi a primeira vez que a
gente fez um projeto para remunerar a
nossa equipe de jovens jornalistas eles
fizeram duas revistas um aplicativo de
celular e um blog E aí pelo Face a gente
blog para que ninguém vai ler nele
textão o calma gente Pessoal tá vamos
respeitar a visão da Juventude vamos
ouvir que ele tem prazer eles são daqui
e foi maravilhoso porque não a
quantidade de 15 mil pessoas a gente
teve catorze mil acessos no blog E aí
tipo pessoal então né vamos falar sobre
coisa que tá com as coisas as pessoas se
identificam com as quartas-feiras pelas
quais as pessoas se interessam se eles
estão daquele Estão dizendo que isso
interessa Pois então interessa mesmo é a
gente pulso legal projeto sucesso tá Um
abraço aquela coisa maravilhosa quando a
gente vai remunerar os meninos Alguém
falou e
aquela dica é diferente a gente arrecada
o dinheiro com prestação de serviço com
projetos editais e tal mas a gente não
remunera individualmente porque todo
esse dinheiro vai pai inclusive oferecer
gratuitamente a oficina que vocês estão
fazendo aí deu que ela vai vir a gente
marcar vontade de brigar assim não mas
eles trabalharam dois meses final de
semana não sei o que a gente segura essa
ansiedade falou não vamos canalizar essa
energia para outro lugar e aí a gente
abriu é nós que é uma escola de
jornalismo para jovens da maioria de 15
a 21 anos alugamos uma casinha no centro
da cidade e lá fomos nós é
diversificar Nossa redação né que ele
tava malhando para o mal da grande
impressa que a gente for putz você
mandar uma diversificada também e aí a
gente começou escolhemos o Centro para
inclusive ficar aí que distante das
periferias para que pudesse Juntar uma
galera de diferentes pontos da cidade aí
a gente não é de educação né a gente a
funcionalismo quer Oi Fran chama a gente
pasteleiro a gente faz pastel do que é
vermelha aí eu falei música
É verdade vocês vão pensar nessa coisa
aí dessa vez tô do logia é a gente ficou
pensando e pensando a partir daquilo que
a gente tinha vivido
e eu acho que a nossa metodologia tem
duas coisas muito importantes que a
escuta e provocação a gente oferece as
ferramentas então tem aula de pauta aula
de texto aula de vídeo mas o que a gente
faz mesmo é escutar o conteúdo e
provocá-los e provocá-las a fazer uma
coisa muito boa gente é só falta sem
foco nem mamãe vai querer ver não dá
refaz eu gente é muito chata nessa
provocação pela qualidade da produção de
conteúdo
o que a gente faz uma coisa muito legal
é Nóiz q é além de da formação toda a
jornalista que a gente faz modelos de
negócio sair Ó tem que tem que ser sexy
também que nem governo que tem que ser
muito sexy que a gente é tudo bem Eu
dinheiro com aquilo que a gente gosta de
fazer e outra coisa vou ler também quero
é boa se o jornalismo quisesse
Reinventar ele tem que aprender a pagar
as contas para continuar sem
independente a gente tá vivendo uma
crise muito séria sobre Olhares
enviesados Sobre conteúdos comprados e
sobre a inação da Imprensa e da
faculdade de jornalismo em paz e
Jornalismo do futuro e pensar como é que
isso vai parar em pé como modelo de
negócio só que da Juju análise não se
não modelo de negócio aí nego tem que
fazer cinco pautas num dia só fala da
Dilma é muita coisa bom Então temos que
pensar nesses mergulhos mais profundos
no fast-food também do jornalismo mas
também nos mergulhos mais profundos por
isso que a gente também da aula de mudar
de negócio é hoje a gente já formou com
a escola de jornalismo 300 jovens nas
periferias de São Paulo isso
presencialmente
é a gente tem todo todo começo de ano
começam 10 alunos de diferentes
periferias a gente passa em um super
processo seletivo eles passam 10 meses
com a gente e recebem 500 réis de bolsa
que não dá para Inovar tem que fazer os
bicos né aquela é um limite muito e eles
são jovens pós-ensino médio crise da
faculdade aliás sobre crise sempre assim
aí como é que tá a crise para vocês a
gente fala gente a gente vive em crise
tá já tinha nunca feliz dinheiro se
abundância e a gente lida com os abole
pessoas em crise por natureza amo minha
mãe aula chata quero falar com essa
menina quero falar com esse menino bom
então assim crise é super recorrente
desliza super bem e mais o pai eu tava
falando pessoal que alentam de passar
pela formação a cada três meses a galera
entrega uma produção jornalística e a
gente montou essa agência para
contribuir com a grande imprensa que a
gente não se esquece dela e porque eles
têm um baita canal de distribuição a
gente tem que ficar ligado né Não dá
para engenheiro que a gente faz projetos
em parceria com as grandes redações é a
gente eles precisam aprender duas coisas
muito importantes com essa molecada que
é como é que faz junto é tipo vamos
fazer uma matéria junto aqui você me
manda um Zap que a gente né eles não
sabe fazer e outra coisa que eles
precisam muito aprender é a saída frente
cada uma coisa estagiária aquele aquela
pessoa que faz aquilo que a gente não
quer fazer
né Ninguém merece gente e aí eu trouxe
dois exemplos para mostrar para vocês
é um aluno nosso Thiago yyoo
ele é negro ele é periférico e ele é
evangélico e ele tava numa gastura no
passado com a história da redução da
maioridade penal
como é que a bancada evangélica passa se
posicionando e ele viu que a bancada
evangélica tava a favor da redução e que
aqui o afetava ele tava nesse vulco
vulco de emoções e a gente tem uma amiga
e professora inclusive da escola de
jornalismo
que trabalha na agência pública que é
uma agência de jornalismo investigativo
que inclusive pauta muitos dos portais e
dos veículos de comunicação como o R7 e
tal e ela tava fazendo uma matéria sobre
formulação de políticas evangélicos Oi e
aí conversando tal se for para você
podia fazer um pedacinho dessa matéria
né eu podia conversar com jovens para
ver como é que a visão dele sobre isso
André falou beleza e aí Thiago eu fico
super animada entrevistou mais de 100
jovens evangélicos de 8 igrejas
diferentes sobre a rede sonoridade penal
sobre formação de jovens políticos de
matéria dele cresceu tanto que virou uma
matéria pense que pegou carona nessa
Distribuição e a gente chegou por outras
portas né pela porta de agência nas
grandes redações foi maravilhoso porque
a gente levou a pauta do Tiago Trio para
dentro da redação
Oi e essa matéria mas não é menos
cabeçuda para dar uma transa aqui vamos
pro rappi árvore
que a matéria no rolê que é uma matéria
sobre balada xó vem vamos lá nós lá na
nossa escola a gente tá conversando com
a galera chega uma mensagem do UOL o
pessoal do altar estava fazendo igual
tabela 11
uma recepção grandes reportagens que a
equipe do wi-fi então fazer uma grande
reportagem sobre Balada Jovem aí aí eu
mando você tem uma fonte aí né nossa não
gente aqui A gente não fornece nem
Fontes nem Estagiários a gente quer
fazer essa lanterninha aí com vocês pode
ser eles toparam também é bom né já tem
não pergunta né não faz a gente
perguntou eles toparam e aí é Uber foi
muito engraçado porque o repórter era
mais velho e ia dirigindo o carro e
levado a equipe de repórteres daí nós
pra balada tipo paizão ele está
desmontando apuração porque eles podiam
entrar na balada né
viu e o Berton ficava esperando tipo Pai
a gente vai sair daí como é que tá Tá
tão filmando direito tá Como é que tá a
produção e foi maravilhoso eu perdi
divertido e aconteceu um fenômeno para o
dessa vez porque o ao que tá acostumado
com um público mais velho teve o fim de
alcançar uma rede Jovem que a gente
também distribui as matérias para nossa
rede e a gente também gosta de fazer
nossas matérias Independentes essa por
exemplo é uma matéria que os meninos
acabaram de fazer e que fala sobre como
consumo interfere na formação da
identidade dos jovens de Periferia super
cabeça eu jamais teria essa ideia eles
fizeram uma grande reportagem multimídia
então tem vídeo foto é teste para ver
qual é o seu perfil uma loucura
G1
Oi e aí eu vou voltar para 2013 Depois
eu falo cura toda quer ser a beleza
é
a Teresa ela
é por isso que 2013 seja um ano tão
marcante porque a Teresa me faz uma
ativista melhor porque ela me faz
repensar o tempo todo nos meus limites
na pessoa que eu sou aí Não quero
parecer deles pois eles vieram fazer
você não acreditaria que o rolo aí eu
falo que não pode ser sim
Oi filha
e a Teresa me faz uma professora ou
melhor porque hoje ele ter a maternidade
onde ela tem que estar aqui vai
maternidade eu deixo de encher o saco
dos meus alunos né eu deixo eles ir
embora eu deixo eles voarem eu dou
autonomia
Bom dia Teresa Então me faz uma pessoa
melhor com ela minha vida deu uma volta
de 360 graus eu sei voltei para o mesmo
lugar e é isso mesmo só que dessa vez eu
voltar para o mesmo lugar eu percebi que
eu não estava mais sozinha
é obrigado a
E aí